The Establishment media Outlets are
collapsing Mass layoffs bankruptcy total
humiliation but rather than rattle off
some of the statistics myself I will
allow a liberal Washington Post
columnist to do it the entire journalism
industry is basically in a freef fall
today the Los Angeles Times laid off 115
employees they wiped out their entire DC
Bureau in an election year they laid off
pretty much all their sports teams they
killed their entire Tech and business
section they laid off breaking news
writers social media editors the list
goes on but what's really dark is this
is just the latest in months and months
and months of layoffs in the media
industry in fact tens of thousands of
journalists have been laid off in the
past year major media companies like
BuzzFeed news have completely shuttered
their news operations Time Magazine also
just laid off a ton of people and oh
Sports Illustrated basically shut down
last week pretty much the entire digital
media ecosystem that myself and a lot of
other Millennial journalists came up in
has been completely hollowed out and
it's not just digital media sites local
news has been obliterated the newspaper
industry is cratering cratering for
reaction we turn now to me when I first
heard this
news
Z my oh my what a wonderful day plenty
of
sunshine in my way zip
[Music]
that was me it's the truth it's actual
everything is satisfactual right now
head on over to woke tears water are you
sick and tired of companies trying to
turn you into a lib seems like this
leftism is everywhere it's in the air we
breathe it's even in the water we drink
that is why there was a new hydration
brand with a mission to save America
from the new woke world one sip at a
time woke tears bottled water is an
American brand that is making hydration
great again woke tears water is a brand
of bottled drinking water right here in
the United States by people who know
what a woman is while everyone else's
water is just water woke tears water
provides a refreshing gulp of laughter
in a world thirsty for sanity not only
will woke tears water keep you hydrated
but you will always have a conversation
starter if you want to try woke tiwater
visit woke Tew water.com indulge today
in laughter and hydration two of the
most important things in this life that
is woke tears
water.com today cocaine Mitch
McConnell has just held reportedly a
closed door
session during which we got two very
juicy little bits of information the
first one he says is we are in a
quandry because Trump's campaign is
apparently going to be largely focused
on
immigration McConnell says the politics
here have changed we can't we can't have
infighting on this thing we don't want
to undermine the the campaign platform
here of trump so we well boy we're in a
real tough spot because this this
immigration issue is going to be really
touchy and there are squished
Republicans like Mitt Romney who don't
want to actually fix
it that's the first juicy bit of
information oh boy we're in a quandry on
immigration here we got it you got to
hold the line little bit
further but number two apparently in
this conversation cocaine Mitch
McConnell Republican leader in the
Senate referred to Trump as the
nominee he says Trump is the nominee of
our party for all intents and purposes
and so you might love Trump you know I
really like Trump I've never made any
bones about the fact that I really like
the guy you might hate Trump as Mitch
McConnell certainly does and as as a lot
of Republicans do especially Republican
politicians but it's just a fact that
he's the
nominee I said this from the beginning
of the primary I really really like
Trump I really really like Ronda santis
I'm really impressed by him I really
obviously I'm been friends with f for
quite some time I really I like Nikki
Haley personally I like a lot of these
guys okay
but Trump's going to be the nominee so
that's that you know politics is the art
of the real the art of the possible
all right the it's it's the art of the
second best as autovon bismar claimed
I'm not saying that Donald Trump is the
second best choice here I'm just saying
that politics is about
reality and he Trump was always going to
be the nominee because we were in this
bizarre situation that we haven't seen
in over a hundred years so if Mitch
McConnell of all people can get on board
with okay it's going to be Trump then
the rest of the GOP probably ought to do
that as well now what what does that
mean in practice there's a Republican
National Committee
who is proposing right now declaring
Trump the presumptive nominee passing a
formal resolution saying we the
Republican National Committee are going
to act as though Trump is the nominee
and Nikki Haley can keep running her
campaign but we are going to just move
on and turn to the general
election while I agree with this RNC
committee man's analysis I don't think
this is a good
idea you you don't want to make us look
like the Democrats here the Democrats
have gone to Federal Court to defend
their right to rig their own election in
in in the case of this one particular
suit to rig it against Bernie
Sanders and the courts have said yeah
you have the right to pick the parties
have the right to pick their nominees we
think of it now as a popular election
where the people have the right to
select the nominees of the parties
that's not true the parties have the
right to select the nominees but the
parties give the people a large say in
it if you're a member of the party I
would let it play out we've only had two
States so far the Iowa caucuses and uh
New Hampshire Trump has won decisively
in both places now the number two guy
from Iowa is is out of the race so it's
Trump the faren away winner of Iowa
versus the number three candidate and
then the race was a little bit tighter
when it just got down to two in New
Hampshire but still Trump won pretty
decisively by what six or seven points
and that was that was Nikki Haley's best
shot next up is Nevada she's not even on
the ballot there she's not going to get
any delegates then after that is South
Carolina Trump's leading her by 30 40
points there and and then you get to
Michigan Trump is leading by a landslide
and then that's you haven't even gotten
to Super Tuesday yet I would just let it
play out I understand the the desire to
say all right let's move on nothing's
going to change here barring some
lightning bolts so let's go fight Joe
Biden but I just think the primary
actually helps Trump and it helps people
who have legitimate problems with
Trump and people who have illegitimate
problems with Trump get through the
grieving process and come to grips with
reality which is that this guy love him
or hate him as the nominee and he did a
good job when he was elected in 2016 and
he exceeded everyone's
expectations uh and he's going to be the
nominee again and he's he's certainly
the best president of my lifetime we've
had a few Republican presidents in my
lifetime he's by far the best one and so
we're going to come to grips with that
as we do it it's kind of like the
lawsuits or rather the the prosecutions
the prosecutions I think seem like they
hurt Trump but they actually help him
because they they make his case before
the American people and I kind of feel
that way about the primary let the let
the voters see a choice between
President Trump and Nikki Haley who has
really embraced the more Centrist
moderate establishment Lane and let them
have the choice and let them vote as
they will that was if I do say so myself
a magnificent clip now you got to ring
the bell and subscribe and you'll get
all the clips and the full episodes and
more even see you next time